Salut la team mentalo !
Aujourd’hui pour ce samedi je vous apprends à bluffer quelqu'un.
Un petit truc, une petite astuce, on pourrait même dire un petit tour en fait, entre la magie et le mentalisme !
C'est parti ! Générique !
[musique]
Il y a quelque chose que je faisais à mes amis voir à ma famille, quand j'étais petit, et qui a toujours étonné tout le monde.
Et personne n'a jamais compris comment je faisais.
Je présentais ça comme étant une prédiction incroyable, alors qu'en fait il y avait une technique très simple pour ça, et c'est ça que je vais vous apprendre.
Vous allez avoir le pouvoir de prédire la fin d'une partie de dominos.
Concrètement vous allez sortir un jeu de dominos. Si vous n'avez pas de jeu de dominos on y reviendra après.
Vous allez tout mélanger et vous dites à la personne en face de vous: "J'aimerai que tu construise toute la partie."
Parce qu'on ne va pas se mentir, il n'y a pas plus simple qu'un jeu de dominos comme règle. Il y a une règle.
Si il y a une 5 ici,
il faut que l'autre domino commence par un 5.
Là si c'est un 3,
il faut que l'autre domino commence par un 3, etc, etc...
Donc vous dites à la personne: "Tu dois relier tous les dominos, tu dois faire une partie avec tous les dominos, il ne doit pas en rester un seul à la fin."
Mais moi, en tant que grand prédicateur, [voix grave], je vais écrire sur un bout de papier,
quel est le domino qui va commencer et quel est le domino qui va finir.
Je vais prédire ça. Tout simplement.
Comme ça, de bon matin.
Effectivement, vous serez en mesure de le faire.
Avec une petite embrouille, on ne va pas se le cacher !
Quelque chose que vous ne savez pas forcément c'est qu'un jeu de dominos complet, doit pouvoir faire une boucle.
C'est-à-dire que si on met bien tous les dominos à la suite, en utilisant tous les dominos, alors on referme complètement.
Le dernier par exemple, ce sera un 2, alors que vous vous aviez commencé par un 2, et ils pourraient se rejoindre.
Ça c'est le méthode même de construction des dominos.
Donc si un jeu de dominos est toujours complet, si on enlève un domino par inadvertance au début de la partie avant même qu'elle ne commence...
alors ce domino peut vous servir de prédiction.
Exemple très concret, si j'enlève un domino 6/1, ça veut dire que les deux extrémités du jeu de dominos faire entièrement, à la fin sera 6 et 1.
Puisque ça aurait du pouvoir se rejoindre.
Et oui c'est malin ça !
Ce qui est d'ailleurs super, c'est que vous pouvez refaire le tour tout de suite après, en remettant le dominos que vous aviez enlevé,
et en en prenant un autre discrètement.
Donc récapitulatif:
Vous prenez un jeu de dominos complet, vous le mettez sur la table, vous mélangez, vous mélangez...
Au préalable vous en avez retiré un et vous savez lequel c'est.
Vous prenez un papier, un crayon, vous marquez votre prédiction.
"Les deux extrêmes de la partie de domino seront 6 et 1."
Si vous avez enlevé le 6/1.
Vous confiez ça à quelqu'un d'autre, la personne en face de vous doit faire le jeu de dominos en utilisant tous les dominos.
Et fin de la partie, on déplie le papier, et ça correspond aux extrêmes.
Si vous n'avez pas de dominos, ce sont des choses qui arrivent,
vous en faites !
Vous prenez une grande feuille A4, là je vous fais en petit pour l'exemple.
Vous dessinez de larges bandes que vous découpez, et puis ensuite vous faites vous même vos dominos.
La seule règle, c'est que vous devez respecter que les jointures soient identiques.
Donc là, si je mets 2 là, je mets 2 là.
Vous devez juste faire un sorte, comme dans un vrai jeu de dominos, que le dernier soit identique au premier.
Donc là par exemple, si je ne faisais que 3 dominos,
je finirai par un 1 ici,
pour que ça puisse faire une boucle.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo du samedi matin.
J'espère que ça vous aura plu.
Plouh ! Plouh ! Plouh ! Plouh !
J'ai rien dit !
Pour ceux qui veulent me voir en spectacle, je joue la semaine en prochaine en Suisse à Lausanne.
Vous avez toutes les infos sur mon site Internet, dans le lien et dans la description.
Je vous reparlerai un petit peu plus de ça la semaine prochaine, parce qu'on est en train de mettre des choses en place pour Lausanne.
Passez un excellent week-end et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à...
ALALAAAH 11H !!! [cri et chante]
Ciao !
[musique]